in this video i'm going to walk you
through the four
scarcest highest value skills that exist
on earth it is the cornerstone upon
which every single top 100 or even top
50 billionaire has built their wealth
before i dive in just as heads up if
you're new to the channel my name is
alex shimozzi i own acquisition.com it's
a portfolio of companies that is about
85 million dollars a year and i have
nothing to sell you all right the reason
i make this channel is a lot of people
are broke and i don't want to be one of
them let's dive in before we get into
each of the four skills all right an
important distinction i need to make
here is that when i'm saying these are
the scarcest skills it is because of two
major things one is that the assumption
is that we are doing these skills at
maximal scale all right number one and
number two is that these are not binary
skills it's not i have it or i don't
have it but it's to what extent do i
have or to what degree do i have it how
masterful am i in this skill and so
these are the four skills that exist and
you will see a clear corollary between
the four ways to create leverage so the
first and easiest one for everyone to
understand and that's why i'm going to
start with it
is the ability to raise
and multiply money which means you have
the skill of getting money from other
people and you can allocate that money
in a way that it multiplies at a higher
rate than anything else right if you
have that skill you can create endless
unlimited fortunes and again at scale
which means you can get lots of money
and you have and you can handle
mass massive sums of money
and you can multiply it because of how
good you are at the skill so that is
scarcest high value skill number one
these are not in order these are just
the top four any of these four if you
have them can
build you to a billion dollars plus
number two
is the ability to capture
and multiply attention
all right and so think about a joe rogan
for example right he's able to build
this this empire that he has because
he's able to capture attention and
multiply attention which is a function
of media mark zuckerberg he was able to
capture attention get people to look at
his app and then tell their friends
multiply attention and so the ability to
capture and multiply attention is the
second
scarce and high value skill that exists
so right now if you're not making the
money that you want to make or you were
poor it's because you're usually not
allocating your time to the highest
value scarcest skills that exist and
oftentimes these skills are not skills
that can be taught but there are skills
that can be learned which is a quote
that i got from the vol ravicon which i
like a lot and oftentimes you'll note
that it's not just one component of this
it's not just being able to raise money
it's being able to also allocate it and
multiply it it's not being able to just
capture attention you have to be able to
use that attention to then multiply the
attention on its own organically at no
incremental cost that's the key point is
that you have to be able to multiply it
at no incremental cost to you that's how
you get unlimited leverage number three
and this is one that a lot of people are
gonna trip up so i'm gonna probably say
this a couple different ways the ability
to return time to other people at no
incremental cost to yourself at scale
so for example if i can save everyone on
planet earth 10 minutes every day i will
be a billionaire
think about that and so the way to
deconstruct that is to think what is
something that lots of people spend time
on is there a way that i can automate
this
and again zero incremental cost which
means this is often going to be some
sort of technology or software solution
no incremental cost to me which means
that if i build this thing one time i
can save everyone
time forever that is a way to build a
fortune that is a way to build billions
and billions of dollars of wealth
that is scarce high value skill number
three so you can
return
time to other people you can decrease
the effort and sacrifice that they
experience in their lives that they do
not want to experience and because it's
at no incremental cost you can sell that
thing to everyone because everyone will
pay something for their time now the
amount maybe may
you know widely vary but if it costs you
almost nothing you can capture an entire
marketplace by giving them time back
what did google do
gave everyone time back now they
obviously multipl they ever they
monetize through advertising but
everyone was looking for something
normally it would take longer to look
for something and then they consolidated
in one place they saved everyone time
the fourth
high value scarcest skill
on planet earth is to be able
to influence the behavior of others at
mass scale
at no incremental cost to you so you
look at someone like jesus or any
prophet i'm not saying he's a prophet
that's not my point here my point is if
you look at the mass leaders probably
shouldn't even brought it up otherwise
people get triggered point is is that
there are people who have walked this
earth
thomas jefferson you know what i mean
people who have had massive
influence
over other people and and
their subsequent behaviors they take as
a result and so this is the ability
to change people's minds if you can help
people change their beliefs and change
their thoughts you will change the way
they behave which is why when people
come to a new faith all of a sudden you
see this massive change in behavior it's
because the operating system and the
lenses through which they see the world
the perspectives that they weigh their
judgments using
have shifted and so if you change the
decision making calculus you change all
of the downstream behaviors that happen
as a result and if you can do this in
concert
at scale
you can a change the world but b you can
also make a ton of money if you look at
the best persuaders of our era
they're ones who for them i would argue
aggregated power because some people at
a certain point you run out of needs for
money you start looking for power
and so if you have the ability to
massively influence
other people
at scale
at no incremental cost to you you have
the fourth
scarce high value roi skill that exists
so right now
mosey nation what it do
if you're looking for ways to increase
your wealth
you can see that all four of these
things are are corollary to the four
types of leverage that exist
these are how fortunes are created
leverage number one is on labor and
actions on on on behalf of other people
towards your goals
so other people do stuff for you
that was the fourth one i just mentioned
all right that's around labor work and
basically actions other people take when
i talked about
money multiplying right that is leverage
using capital
so the ability to maximally
raise and multiply capital at scale
is a high value scale the third
is being able to give people their time
back what we're talking about this is a
good friend of mine who's a technologist
he says all technology automates luxury
and luxury is typically a function of
convenience effort and sacrifice and so
we look at the places where people spend
time and spend effort and sacrifice and
we return it back to them at no
incremental cost that is how you create
scale using technology right and the key
resource we're giving people back is
time
and then the fourth and final one
is
media all right and so
using media and being able to multiply
uh media
via the capturing and multiplication of
attention because ultimately media is
just the substrate through which
impressions are conveyed to other people
signals that they are interpreting
through their senses the idea is how can
we capture as many senses as we can and
then get those senses to get other
people plugged into our thing and then
in so doing it will compound and so one
of the key notes to note about each of
these four things that i just mentioned
is that each of these skills compound
they are not multiplicative they are not
additive they are not incremental they
are compounding which means they are
exponential in nature a lot of people
say it's an exponential growth they
don't even know what exponential means
but it means that it multiplies unto
itself and then each time it multiplies
itself bigger upon itself not just like
we we 2x every year but it would have to
be when we incrementally go 10 10 10
growth that is where is compounding and
each of these
in the form of labor
people are influenced people tell other
people people tell other people they do
the thing for you and it compounds
with capital the money that you multiply
gets you more money which you then
multiply it compounds
the time you save people more time which
then gets you more people to save time
for and it compounds
with attention you capture the attention
you multiply the intent because those
people tell other people and then the
intention comes back and so each of
these are quadratic in nature in terms
of the skills and those my friends are
where you focus your time if you want to
create a fortune and so you can look at
your skill set right now and say which
of these skills do i lack or which of
these four buckets do am i currently at
least working somewhat directionally
towards and then we can again think this
is not a binary checklist if i have the
skill or i do not have the skill but to
what degree to what extent am i a master
of this thing and so lots of love mosey
nation keep being awesome i make this
channel because a lot of people broke
and i don't should be one of them i
think i said this earlier but uh my name
is alex ramose i own acquisition.com you
know all the dollars things like that
and i'll see you guys next video bye